this is rainbow a red sided eclectus  perish that deep green plumage with a  tint of blue signifies that rainbow is a  male bird female eclectus 'as have deep  red feathers and until the 20th century  males and females were considered  different species native to Papua New  Guinea these beautiful birds nest high  up in the tropical rainforests they are  considered to be extremely intelligent  birds and amongst the best in talking  ability for parrots their vocal skills  and stunning plumage have made them  highly desirable in the pet trade while  logging and other forms of habitat  destruction have caused their population  to decline steadily this is the red  sided eclectus parrot  you